Time sensitive applications require quickly responding
to an event. Think of playing a
video game and shooting at a target. You want the instant that you shoot
at the target for action to appear on the screen. Now, problem is there
are three sources of latency for time
sensitive events, in any typical general purpose
operating system. The first source of latency
is what is called the timer latency.
That is coming because of the inaccuracy
of the timing mechanism. For instance, the timer
event went off at this point, but
the timer interrupt actually happens only here.
That is, this is the event that
should have resulted in an interrupt, but because
of the inaccuracy of the timer, there's a
latency between the point at which an even
happened, an external event. And the point at
which the timer goes off indicating that external event.
And this is primarily coming up due to
the granularity of the timing mechanism that's available in
general purpose operating systems. For instance, periodic timers
tend to have a ten millisecond granularity in Linux
operating system. So that's the first source of inaccuracy or
latency for time sensitive applications. The second
source of latency is what we call as the as the preemption latency.
And this is because of the fact that the interupt could have happened when the
kernel was in the middle of doing something from which it can not be preempted.
For instance, when the kernel is modifying some critical
data structure. In that case it may have turned off
the interrupt and therefore even though the interrupt went off
at this point the kernel cannot be preempted until this
point. That may be the second source of latency
or it could be that the kernel itself is in
the middle of handling another higher priority interrupt. And in
that case, this time interrupt is going to be delayed.
So that the second source of latency
for time sensitive applications running on commodity operating
systems. Okay, finally the timer interrupt has been
delivered to the system and now the scheduler
can actually schedule the process that is
waiting for this timer interrupt so that that
application can take the appropriate action for this
external interrupt. But wait, there is another high
priority task that's already in the scheduler's
queue and therefore the app that was waiting
for this timer event cannot yet be
scheduled because of this higher priority tasks that
has dibs on the processor at this point of time. So this is the third
source of latency, that is the scheduler latency.
That is preventing this external event from being
delivered to the application that is waiting
for this particular event. Now finally the high
priority app is done, and therefore now it is time for the app that is actually
waiting for this event. So this is the point of activation of the Event app,
that is, the app that is waiting for this timer event. So you can see that this
is the distance TA to Th. The difference between TA and Th is the
event to activation distance. The event happened here, but the app that can
react to this event only gets scheduled at this point, and this is
the latency that is coming in for
time-sensitive applications between the actual event happening.
And the activation of the app that has to
deal with that particular event. For time sensitive applications
to do well, it is extremely important that we
shrink this distance between event happening, and event activation.